hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in Aristotle's Poetics when he's looking
at the elements of tragedy he tells us
that plot or muthos which can also be
translated as story is the most
important element or part of tragedy and
he calls it a construction or a
structure these are different
translations that we can use for
synthesis and sunstasis bringing things
together that sun should tell you that
we're looking for some sort of unity of
different parts and it is a structure of
events
pragmata right so pragmatar are the
things that are actually done or the
things that we care about Affairs is
another way of Translating that term and
so the plot is supposed to be bringing
together different things into some sort
of coherent whole and we can ask
ourselves Aristotle gives us definitions
of tragedy and then adds a little bit to
it how does the construction of the
structure of the events the plot how
does this contribute to the parts of the
definition that we're interested in here
tragedy is itself a mimesis an imitation
representation we could also say of
action proxies which is a word which is
correlative to pragmatone actions what
are done or the effects right these are
fused together
and it's a mimesis of action that is
elevated spudias or we could translate
that as serious right
this is an important aspect it's not
just trivial matters
complete teleas this is a really
important term here brought to its
fruition we could say of magnitude
um you know there's different ways of
expressing that in Greek and Aristotle
uses them and then a little bit later
he's going to mention that it is
right entire and that kind of goes with
the complete right so we could say that
these these are all connected with each
other how do they how does a plot
produce that effect
for us how does it successfully
produce tragedy so Aristotle is going to
give us some insights along the way in
the work and one of these has to do with
um
it may seem very common sensical to you
but but actually it's not and this is
why a lot of people are bad writers or
bad conceivers or Bad actors he says a
whole is that which has a beginning a
middle and an n and this again may seem
very common sensical to you but a lot of
times people lose sight of this right so
it has an Arcane a beginning and our hay
has a certain meaning here that we're
going to unpack a uh middle part of
Meson right a joining thing and then an
end tele now there's notion and to that
otane is connected with to Leos and the
notion of end as like where we're going
with things not just that it finishes
and then screen goes blank and we're
like oh what happened there right the
way sometimes uh
series can do frustrating people because
I don't know the ending it's a little
bit more complex than that
so we want to think out the connections
and we could even say the causality what
is a beginning he tells us a beginning
is that which does not itself follow
necessarily from something else but
after which a further event or process
naturally occurs so the the beginning is
kind of an arbitrary starting point but
it's one that we choose because it's apt
and then things flow from it right what
about an end an end is that which
naturally occurs whether necessarily or
usually after a preceding event but need
not be followed by anything else a
middle is that which both follows a
preceding event and has further
consequences so we've got you know all
these connections and we've got
relations of this causes this or this
leads to this right this produces the
situation in which this character
chooses this so Aristotle is going to
talk about well constructed plots to
sunestos muthos is the plot right ew
well soon esto Tas put you know well put
together we could say and so what is
characteristic of a well-constructed
plot it should not begin or end at an
arbitrary point
it is arbitrary in the sense that like
everything can be looked at from
different points of view but as far as
the unity of The Story Goes you tell the
story beginning at the place where it
needs to start you finish it up at the
point where it needs to end and you
don't have to go any further I mean it's
kind of interesting to think about this
in our own time which is just obsessed
with lore and prequels and sequels
a good constructed plot stands on its
own it doesn't say well we'll get this
explained in the next movie or the next
installation it it is a Unity it can
work by itself if no other thing is ever
produced that is sufficient right and he
says that it shouldn't begin or end at
an arbitrary point but should make use
of the patterns the ideas that we have
already presented to you so that's uh
something that's quite important and
then we can think about
some other aspects including the
magnitude and this has to do with the
amount of time
that we're going to devote to a play how
long should a play be an Aristotle you
know earlier he did say well typically
tragedy happens within the scope of one
day he's not saying it always has to be
like that right he's just saying that's
a a descriptive statements not a
normative statement as many people have
taken it to be but it's got to be the
right amount of time
and he says that a limit of length
referring to competitions and powers of
attention of the audience is extrinsic
to the art right what we actually want
to think about is the limit the horos uh
the the dividing line that conforms to
the matter that we're looking at in the
play and it can be uh longer if the play
really is well unified if it's really
well constructed provided that you have
Clarity or coherence
so Mercury means up to that point of
things still being clear enough can your
audience follow what's actually
happening here if so then the more that
you have the better the play is provided
you don't go to the point where it
starts to break down and people can't
figure out what's going on right so uh
he says how long should this be the size
which allows a transformation to occur
in now notice this in a probable or
necessary sequence of events from
adversity to Prosperity or prosperity to
adversity that is a sufficient limit of
magnitude and we're going to come back
to this probability or necessity in just
a bit the next thing that he tells us
which is really quite interesting is
that one failing strategy for having a
unified play is to focus it entirely
around one character in the play or the
individual as he says right it tells us
that a plot is not unified as some
people think so people are making
mistakes with this if Bill built around
one individual why because as he says an
entity has innumerable features not all
of which cohere into a unity in an
individual performs many actions which
yield no unitary action and he says that
you know poets go wrong with this Homer
did a better job in The Odyssey why he
doesn't tell us what Odysseus had for
breakfast this is not from Aristotle
this is just my uh you know being
facetious here he doesn't tell include
every feature of the hero's life where
the events lacked necessary or probable
connections but he has structured The
Odyssey around a unitary action so this
gives you an idea unitary action if you
read The Odyssey it's a long word right
but it all is all one unitary action as
Aristotle is going to say so you can
have a single important character or you
know more than one but you need more
than that to provide unity and here's
where we get to you're talking about
probability and necessity so he's going
to contrast this against plots that are
episodic right plots where things are
just kind of thrown all together epic
episode is is how the Greek runs here
and he says that by episodic I mean a
plot a story in which the episodes the
little portions of the work
follow one another without probability
or necessity so probability acos things
you know seeming plausible it seems like
this would actually make sense or a
necessity if this happens well then this
has to happen right things flow from
each other by necessity
so a plot that doesn't unify the story
the characters the actions in this way
is not going to be a very good plot and
it's going to ruin the tragedy and
notice what he says about this bad poets
do this through their own fault because
they can't do any better good poets do
it for the sake of the actors they can
they construct show pieces and they
stretch the plot Beyond its capacity
here instead of like focusing at just on
a character we focus it on the actor
right and then we make the character too
important in the play and things don't
hold together it's more of a character
study than anything else and so Ayers
little thinks that if you want to have a
a good unified plot absolutely necessary
for tragedy you got to put some thought
into this and this leads us into the
advice that he provides a little bit
later on about how to do this
right he says that people should
construct plots and work them out in
language and diction
with the material as much as possible in
the Mind's Eye right
um and so
omaton right the Mind's Eye we could
actually think about visualization as
well here so he tells us that by seeing
these things vividly as if you're
present at the events you're thinking
about your play and how things are going
you can discover what is actually most
appropriate this is an important term in
Greek and you can also not mix or Miss
contradictions they will not be veiled
literally for you and he says that you
know if you look at some of these
ancient plays he mentions
um uh you know
One play that we don't actually have the
play actually didn't work the audience
was annoyed at it why because they
didn't think it out ahead of time how it
would actually appear for an audience
and he goes on and he tells us that you
know we should first lay out the general
structure and then develop the sequence
of episodes so instead of like saying oh
I've got this really cool scene I've
written I want to figure out a play
around it think about what your overall
action is going to be and that is going
to help you to have some sort of
overarching unity to it and then you
start writing the different parts to fit
that and bringing the characters and
their actions and all the other elements
that we think are important together
into something that should remain a
complex and dynamic Unity